what obviously your
your first meeting with bullios you was
very pleasant
yeah so the first time i went over there
and this was what was interesting too
and for people who
people listening who aren't familiar
with will remind you biliosi was
the prosecutor right on on manson's
trial juliossi was an unknown prosecutor
in 1969
and he was given a career-making case
you know this is the highest profile
murders
in the history of california the
craziest case
and not only did he know it was his
ticket out of the da's office and then
he wanted to run for president and or be
a famous
author not only did he know it was his
ticket out
he got a book contract and hired an
author
to sit in the front row of the trial
every day for a year and a half
which today would get you this bar but
back then they didn't have
the bar association didn't have rules
about it because nobody did it until he
did it
people never knew he did it until i
reported it in my book
because kirch entry that his co-author
told me well
the cops told me you know who were at
the at the courthouse every day you know
he had a damn author in there
he was playing for his reading audience
he didn't care about justice
he was making it as sensational as
possible and kurt gentry told me that's
the truth he said i had a spot
in the press thing that vince reserved
for me and he would be pissed if i
wasn't there every single day
so um yeah so he wrote the book and it
became the best-selling book of all time
and then is this still the best-selling
book of all time true crime yeah true
crime book of all time well you know i
i say that in my book and little brown's
like we have to fact check that
and they said you know what that's we're
not going to fact check it we know
it's likely but we can't get records
from all the way back to 75
right but we do know that it sold
millions and millions and millions of
copies i think it's sold like
18 million or something over it's always
reprinted
so it launched his career and he left
the da's office right after
and he wanted to run for he did want to
be president
so he was famous he was on talk shows
interviewed by everybody in the world
and he ran
for the district attorney of los angeles
and a few months before the race he was
the democratic nominee and
he would have won except the couple came
out and went
public herb and rose wiesel
this is the craziest stories on the book
herb wiesel was a milkman in pasadena in
1964
and the bouilloses were on his route
vince had his first
child vince bouliosi jr in 65 i think it
was
within a year of the baby's birth vince
decided
that it wasn't his child that it was the
milkman's child
so he started stalking the milkman and
harassing him and the milkman didn't
know
who was accusing him of being the father
of one of his
clients or a customer's child except
that it was
a man who had eyes everywhere what he
didn't know was vince
was using investigators for the da's
office to trail him
and report on him and he told the
investigators that he was a witness in a
murder case
lied to his own office to get info
because he was just paranoid about did
he actually believe this guy was the
real father or was he just
he did and he so much so that he he
picked up the kids at school
and when the parents found that out they
had to
they said to the kids you can't ride the
bus home anymore he intercepted them on
the way to the bus
picked them up the daughter told me this
story she got in touch with me after the
book came out
this way just a little bit just scoot to
your right just a little bit yeah
you're just getting out of frame there
you go the daughter wrote me an email
after
and i wrote about a lot of this but what
i'm telling you now i didn't i knew that
the parents thought he was gonna do
something with the kids because he
talked about when they got out of school
he would write these anonymous letters
to them i have one or two of them on my
instagram page because i post stuff up
about it yeah um and they're threatening
letters saying you know implying that
he's going to hurt their kids
the daughter wrote me after and she goes
you got everything in your book about
what he did to our family is right but
you didn't get a lot
of other stuff which i'll share with you
and i'm like what what kind of stuff and
she goes well for instance
he picked me up at school took me to a
toy store i
told me i could buy whatever i wanted
brought me home
left me on the sidewalk with this pile
of toys i was five years old
my mother comes to the door and vince
waves to her and drives away
and she said my mother just burst into
tears because she had already been
you know they knew that there was this
man who was a danger to their kids and
he was sending them a message
i can win your kids over if i want this
is while he's a deputy d.a
prior to getting a sign this guy's a
psychotic piece of [ __ ]
yeah and then what happened was the
milkman finally hired
someone to tell vince because he would
sit in front of their house
and watch them so vince knew he was
being tailed and he was about to be
exposed but he didn't think the milkman
would go public and the man wasn't going
to go public he just wanted him to stop
so vince sent his wife gail to the door
to insist to the other wife to talk her
husband into taking a blood test
so gail gets goes to the door rose
answers and this is all in the
depositions that came out later
and she said my husband is mentally ill
that child is his child but he won't
believe me and the only way to get him
to stop this
is for you to get your husband to take a
blood test and she goes i absolutely
won't do it
and we are going to sue you for
everything as soon as we find out
who your husband is because they still
didn't know his name
um so i think it was that day or the
next day
they did get vince's plate number they
found out who he was
they contacted the da's office no they
contacted first they found out that
vince had a private lawyer so they
called him
that lawyer arranged for a meeting
between the couple
and vince and his wife and then
submitted everything
he said i'm sorry he goes i thought he
made my wife
pregnant and i wanted to know whether
this is my baby or not what's wrong with
that
and they're like you've been sending us
threatening letters you parked outside
our house you picked up our
all this stuff so you lied to your own
your own office and told them it was
murder searching them for murder
so the lawyer said vince
you can't do that anymore and if this
the da's office didn't know about it he
said they're gonna find out about it so
the
i'm gonna have to tell them because it's
better coming from us than you
you have to pay them a financial
settlement and promise you'll never
follow them
so vince offered them 200 in cash and
the wise elves said we don't want your
money
we want your word that you will never
bother us again
and he didn't um a year later
the tatella bianca murders happened the
da's office knows about this history
of vince and they give him
the biggest highest profile job in los
angeles
you'll see in the book i believe they
needed somebody
that they could control as a d.a who
would be a cro
you know who would break the rules and
vince was compromised
someone they had leverage on so this
story didn't become public until he ran
for district attorney of los
angeles after the manson convictions
after he left the da's office
he runs for the d.a and the wise elves
never wanted to go public with this but
they thought
that's the most powerful law enforcement
person in the city
he's insane look what he did to us so
they went to his opponent
and said we have a story to tell and the
opponent said well you tell
the public that and they said absolutely
so they stood on a stage there was a
press conference
and they told what i just told you
actually i might have told you more than
they told because they didn't i don't
think they knew about the da's
investigators until they actually had
the civil suit
so vince responded with his own um
press conference and he told the media
here's what happened
that man was our milkman in 1964
and he stole 200 from our kitchen table
when i was at work and my wife was
upstairs he delivered the milk
and he stole two hundred dollars i was
investigating
him for the theft of two hundred dollars
now listen you know the press didn't ask
these questions but they
he basically called that him a thief
the lawyer for the wise elves didn't say
it then but he told the police
or the reporters later number one that
story can't be true
because vince wouldn't have been
investigating him in 1966
whatever the date was the statute of
limitation on home robbery or whatever
was two years
so he was saying he was investigating
for a 200
theft more than two years after right
he said right i called the pasadena
police department
why didn't he ask them to investigate it
they have no record of
this theft being reported so we're going
to sue him for libel
and then it went to court and vince paid
them a fortune
and the agreement was they could never
go public
he admitted to telling the lies wow
then vince lost the election and then
two years later he runs for attorney
general of california
even bigger position and a woman comes
to his opponent
in virginia carwell and she said he
shouldn't be the attorney general
she beat the [ __ ] out of me held me
captive made me lie to the police she
had gotten pregnant with his baby
and he he gave her i think 300
to get an abortion and
called the doctor and the doctor said
she never even showed i mean the
doctor's not supposed to
say anything but since it's been polio
yeah
the doctor said she didn't come in for
an abortion he went to her house and she
said i'm catholic i'm not getting
aborting that baby he
beat the [ __ ] out of her for like four
hours she went to the santa monica
police department i have the photographs
you know
black and blue everywhere uh she had a
miscarriage
and then after he beat her yeah yeah and
then
that night someone saw it on that one of
the journalists that one of the papers
saw it on the ticker or whatever
you know they see everything that comes
in and out of the police station
booliosi
accused of assault and kidnapping
by a woman so the next day it was in the
l.a times the los angeles herald that
this famous prosecutor had beaten up
this woman
and uh and this is before he ran for
attorney general
he was writing the book at that point
held her skelter
and vince went back to her house
with his secretary held her captive for
four or five hours
until she agreed to go to the police and
say she filed a fake report
so um the secretary typed up
a receipt and the story they came up
with
was that virginia who had recently gone
through a divorce
had consulted with vince about uh
custody payments her husband her
ex-husband wasn't paying for the
five-year-old kid who was in the house
when all this stuff happened
and had never had a sexual relationship
with him he'd never been to her house
and so she was gonna go to the police
station
and they called her up because they
wanted her to come back in for more
questioning and vince was in the house
with her and so was his secretary
i was like no i did not and she said
what you want me to come
okay you're going to send a car
she said oh no i'm fine i can go they
knew something was funny
so they sent the cops anyway and vince
was still there he wouldn't let them in
the house
and i interviewed the cop who who came
to try to get her out of the
out of the house he eventually did then
what happened was the police interviewed
vince and he lied to them
he said she's in love with me she's
stalking me
and it's just over a two hundred dollar
bill
so um again with the two hundred dollar
two three hundred dollars yeah
so then um she still
told the story to the police that she
had made it all up because she was angry
at him for charging her
because she was terrified of them and it
wasn't until a couple days and the
papers reported that she was crazy and
she was charged you know with filing a
false report
vince was vindicated and then a couple
days later her brother said
she told her brother and he said no
we're hiring a lawyer you can't let this
go on on a dress so they quietly filed a
lawsuit against him
he admitted to everything paid her i
think ten
thousand dollars or something and then
a year later runs for attorney general
and she did the same thing the wise
elves did
they had they violated their nda and she
violated hers
and she knew he'd call her a liar but
she knew he couldn't sue her
because he'd have to answer the
questions
so he lost the race again because of
that because everyone believed her and
not him
right so he was a monster you know and
uh
he that was the end of his political
aspirations but he did
write probably 15 best-selling books for
the next 20 or 30 years until he died